he's got the common sense of a
potato so right now that there there are
a bunch of nominees to be in military
positions who are hung up right now uh
because they you know we go through a
process right you you are vetted they
want to find out what your thinking is
what your policies are Etc this is what
the Senate does and Senator Tommy tuber
bill from Alabama he's a republican uh
he's holding up a bunch of these
nominees Because he believes that a lot
of these people are woke that they want
to inject gender and sexual and skin
color and all the rest of it into the
military so he's trying to find out more
about these people but look how Anna
Naro goes after him or doing what we all
know is the right thing she also makes a
joke here about a potato that makes no
sense to me but if any of you can figure
it out I would love to love to know what
it is your point about uniting against
terrorism it it occurred to me this
weekend you know we're we're sending two
aircraft carriers to the Middle East
there's going to be there's about 10,000
servicemen there and women we have
Marines and the and hor moves and we
have got a senator from Alabama in the
US Senate who is holding up over 350
appointments of Admirals and Generals
and leaders in the military Senator
tuberville it is time that you stop this
stupidity because we need our military
leaders confirmed he's so apply named
tuberville cuz he's got the common sense
of a
potato okay I didn't get the joke who he
didn't get the joke I'm told that
potatoes what are you telling me now are
a
tuber a potato is a stem tuber his name
is tuberville actually so I
mispronounced it as well but a potato is
a stem tubber I I don't know what that
means but but that's the potato joke was
not the point the point was you see how
she's connecting this the guy's trying
to stop some of the woke stuff from
getting in our military I don't I don't
know anything about these 300 some odd
Admirals that that are trying to get in
but like we do know we have a problem
but you see how the Liberals they get
everything wrong right so Ana abaro has
basically gotten everything wrong for
the last 5 years then finally she sees a
burned baby and she makes sense for one
day but then the next day it immediately
is now the Republicans are bad because
they're not giving us everything we
want